finding a mistake in a Disney movie can
be irritating but it can also be the
perfect excuse for revisiting some of
our favorite Disney movies watch until
the end to see how Pocahontas includes
some of Disney's biggest mistakes if
this is your first time visiting the
things don't forget to subscribe and
please give this video a big thumbs up
here's ten times Disney made huge
mistakes
Aladdin's inaccurate Anatomy as soon as
they took flight for their magic carpet
ride jasmine and the Ladin's Love Story
was one for the books
Aladdin is a hilarious Disney movie
loved by generations however the movie
is not perfect Disney made one major air
when it came to Aladdin's body
Aladdin remains virtually topless for
the majority of the film often only
wearing a purple vest though he seems
pretty chiseled and hairless Aladdin
specs are missing nipples a BuzzFeed
article points out that this is an
exception from other Disney male
characters including Tarzan King Triton
Milo from Treasure Island Hercules and
most of the men in Mulan the
inconsistencies emphasized the lack of
nipples for Aladdin's character must
have been a mistake
however Aladdin isn't alone in his bare
chested image a hello giggles article
pointed out that there are other Disney
contemporaries that also seem to have
suffered the same neglect such as Mowgli
in The Jungle Book and Gaston from
Beauty and the Beast do you think this
was a conscious decision on Disney's
part or just a mistake we can't figure
out what would dictate the right to bear
nipples or not but it's certainly a hard
detail to notice once you're aware of it
these older portraits the story might be
as old as time but print Adam sure isn't
Beauty and the Beast is a timeless
classic and the live-action remake with
Emma Watson just makes it that much more
relevant to enjoy ever notice how every
time you watch a movie you notice more
details about them this can be finding
out more about the story or characters
involved but in Disney's case it can
also mean discovering some and logical
mistakes vows finding out about beasts
curse is a turning point in their
relationship while the Beast works on
showing her more of his vulnerability
Belle
to see through his hideous exterior at
the beginning of the movie the audience
learns about Prince Adams vanity and
shallowness that resulted in him being
cursed to remain a beast forever unless
he can find someone to love him before
he turns 21
Lumiere expresses that this happened 10
years prior to when the film takes place
that would mean that Prince Adam
couldn't have been more than eleven
years old when he was cursed by The
Enchantress
yet the portrait of him shows him as a
young man Disney definitely made a
mistake with their calculations but the
magic of the movie remains just as
effective Hercules the fiction Disney's
Hercules was absolutely based on Greek
mythology though there are so many
mistakes that it should be made clear
that percolates isn't just an adoption
of the myth but a reimagining for
example Hercules is a Roman name so to
conform to Greek myth his name should be
spelled Heracles or Hera class Hera is
Hercules whose mother in the movie but
this is another mistake Hercules was
born to Zeus and a Clemmie who was a
mortal human making Hercules at demigod
the five News is in the movie provide
the audience with great entertainment
but not with great information as there
are nine others missing Hades is a great
villain but he never did try to kill
Hercules Hera on the other hand did she
was jealous to find out that Zeus her
husband had snuck into another woman's
bed and had a baby she wanted to get
revenge by killing the child from that
union Hercules
Hades actually played a very minor role
in the legend he wasn't even appointed
the rule of the underworld by Zeus
rather the two had to roll dice to see
who would be in charge these are just
some examples of how a great story
doesn't always make it the true story
Cinderella's wedding dress it has been
said that girls dream about their
wedding dress from a very young age a
lot of wedding gowns even try to
reproduce a princess ballgown look
especially that of Cinderella's upon a
close look it seems that Disney had
trouble deciding on this perfect dress
as the animated princess is seen wearing
two different styles in the final scene
of the movie a transformational moment
for Cinderella arrives when she is magic
greeted by her fairy godmother who casts
a spell to save the day and conjures a
beautiful ball gown for Cinderella to
wear to the ball after tirelessly
working on a dress that have been
destroyed by her stepsisters the
audience's attention is drawn to the
importance of the right gown for the
occasion with up bibbidi-bobbidi-boo
apparently the same attention to outfit
detail is not included first
Cinderella's dress from her carriage it
can clearly be seen that Cinderella's
wearing a long-sleeved gown
however from the back window as the
newlyweds kiss Cinderella is shown in a
different dress that is sleeveless with
a puffy shoulder strap only Cinderella's
fairy godmother is nowhere to be seen
it's somehow this wardrobe change is
included without any explanation
ratatouille
hidden complements what's not to love
about a movie set in Paris centered
around food with an adorable rat
protagonist when Anton ego the scary
skeleton like food critic comes to judge
the dishes served at Gusto's
he's impressed with the restaurants
comeback years earlier Anton ego left an
insulting review for the restaurant that
he categorized as another tourist trap
while trying to seem insulting Disney
made a mistake that completely
undermines his character's bad
intentions in his negative review he
claimed that the Stowe has found his
place in history alongside chefs like
Mon jewel boy OD it can only be assumed
that this was a jab at the fact that the
food tasted like it was processed one
thing that Disney failed to verify is
that Chef at door Hector Midori was a
successful businessman who created the
brand but was also a very talented chef
among his accomplishments are his
position as head chef at the famous
Plaza Hotel his ownership of his own
restaurant and his catering for
President Woodrow Wilson's wedding
reception turns out a comment meant as
an insult turned out to be a compliment
it doesn't seem like Disney did their
research for this line but the joke
still seems to land anyway the Emperor's
New Groove The Emperor's New Groove
stands out as being very different from
a typical Disney movie for one thing
there isn't much of an emphasis on love
or romance and
main character Cusco doesn't have a love
interest at all for the duration of the
movie meanwhile he's not very likable
compassionate or sympathetic unlike most
of Disney's main characters finally the
movie points out parts that don't really
make sense and the comedy and pace of
dialogue have a different feel to them
than what is usual for a Disney movie
all these differences could be in part
due to one of Disney's big mistakes that
can be perceived through an error in the
movies opening song Cusco is called an
enigma and a mystery in Mesoamerican
history Disney got the geography wrong
when it comes to the movie setting as it
is based off the Incan Empire which was
further south and parts of northern and
Central America the movie actually is
set in the Andes Mountains which is near
modern-day Peru in fact the movie was
originally titled
the kingdom of the Sun and it was
intended to be a completely different
movie
maybe this mistake points to the earlier
plans Disney had a store The Lion King
savanna animals who can't conjure up the
opening to the Lion King as all the
animals in the savanna congregate to
welcome their new king sadly don't plan
on taking away any lessons on natural
habitats from the movie as Disney made
several mistakes and one take giant
anteaters and leaf cutter ants are shown
neither of which can be found on the
entire continent of Africa as they are
both native to the Americas shadow land
is bands from Simba's adventures as the
elephant graveyard is deemed to be
dangerous territory it turns out that
elephant graveyards
aren't actually a bank though elephants
do roam away from their herd in order to
die alone there's no evidence that they
go to a collective resting spot also the
likelihood of all these animals being in
the same spot in Africa is extremely low
as they occupy different regions of the
continent of course in a movie where
animals talk and sing to one another in
English we need to be able to suspend
our disbelief nevertheless it's
important to realize that what we see in
movies even about nature could very well
be part of the fiction instead of based
on facts magical swords and instruments
in
then frozen was a huge hit for its
original storyline hit songs message and
characters we love the story was just
different enough for it to be refreshing
but included all of the Disney tropes
including protagonist discovering who
they are and where they belong
one typical Disney aspect it also
included maybe unintentionally is a
couple unadoptable mistakes whatever
magic is involved in the movie the rules
and laws surrounding the Magic has to be
taken with a grain of salt in frozen's
Elsa's ice cream powers are explained
but Hans sword wheeling powers are not
fondest sword appears and dissapears
several times throughout the movie
including in the final scene however the
swords and magical properties are never
explained unexplained magical or
mistakes and objects don't stop at
Honda's sword Christophe has also shown
playing a musical instrument that
obviously has four strings but only
three tuning pegs he also makes mistake
in the lyrics using the plural of
reindeer incorrectly and says reindeers
instead that is a particularly odd
mistake as Kristoff spends much of his
time around the animals and would have
known the terminology for guarding them
in any case these unexplained details
are clearly mistakes unless Disney is
waiting for a sequel to provide us with
answers forbidden waltz everyone loves
watching movie characters break out in
dance moves even when they're animated a
romantic dance between a prince and a
princess has been the apex of several of
Disney movies sometimes style has the
potential to outweigh substance leading
to some mistakes
Disney definitely fell prey to this
error in Sleeping Beauty when Prince
Phillip and Aurora dance their waltz
Prince Philip does a great job at
pointing out the movies time period to
the audience when he tells his father
that he is living in the past as it is
now the 14th century the waltz on the
other hand was only popularized as a
style of dance in the 16th century the
waltz didn't spread through Europe and
called the 17th century in fact in the
14th century the only kind of physical
contact a couple could enjoy while
dancing would be hand contact while line
dancing even during the time of the
waltz it was discouraged by older
generations who taught it to be
incredibly obscene and inappropriate
made a huge mistake when they had their
main character dance with their princes
hands on her waist this would have been
scandalous at the time
Disney has been caught up in
controversies long before we even
realized Pocahontas is problems
Pocahontas is so riddled with mistakes
it had to make the top of our list not
only are these mistakes plentiful but
they are also quite serious and lead to
negative stereotypes against Native
communities and customs as it
misrepresented a historical history that
actually happened
for starters even our protagonists name
is one of Disney's mistakes as it's only
a nickname that translates to mean the
naughty one or spoiled child Disney's
main mistake has to be that they turned
down the PO wotton people who wanted to
help consult in the movie ultimately if
the Pilat and people express their
disapproval of the movie and say that it
distorts history beyond recognition
it's one thing for Disney to want to
tell a story that culturally does not
belong to them but it was a huge mistake
to not have consultation by a member of
the community whose story they were
attempting to tell it also led to
further mistakes in the movie including
Pocahontas age who would only have been
10 or 11 it's one thing to make a
fictional narrative and make mistakes in
the process the fact that Pocahontas was
a real story and her nation faced
British colonizers with a lot more
conflict and much less romance than
Disney shows makes it one of its biggest
mistakes and that's all for 10 times
Disney made huge mistakes if this is
your first time visiting the things
don't forget to subscribe
and please give this video a big thumbs
up see you next time